recuerdo que busca aliviar la escasez
mundial fue prorrogado por otros 120
días aunque la ONU y Ucrania pedían que
fuera por un año kiev podrá continuar
con la exportación de sus granos por el
mar Muerto la voz
profundamente saber que en Estambul
Turquía Ucrania Rusia y la ONU llegaron
a un acuerdo para la renovación de la
iniciativa de granos del mar Negro lo
que permite la libre exportación de
granos ucranianos
quiero expresar mi profundo compromiso y
el compromiso de la ONU de hacer todo lo
posible para la implementación sin
problemas de estos acuerdos en Estambul
el acuerdo alcanzado en julio permitía
la reanudación de las exportaciones
desde tres puertos de Ucrania un
importante productor de cereales y
oleaginosas con las que puede producirse
aceite vegetal
Moscú también se verá beneficiado del
acuerdo
sí por supuesto hay el día de la ONU de
que se finalizará el trabajo para
garantizar la exportación de alimentos y
fertilizantes rusos notamos que el
trabajo de las Naciones Unidas ha dado
resultados una declaración conjunta de
los Estados Unidos Gran Bretaña y la
Unión Europea sobre la eliminación del
régimen de sanciones para los
exportadores de productos alimenticios y
fertilizantes rusos
Este es un movimiento importante y
positivo y este trabajo finalizará
eliminando todos los problemas directos
e indirectos de esta manera desde julio
se han enviado unos 11,1 millones de
toneladas de productos agrícolas en el
marco del acuerdo sobre cereales
incluidos 4,5 millones de toneladas de
maíz y 3,2 millones de toneladas de
trigo el presidente Turco recepto allí
verduán un actor clave en las
negociaciones propuso que el grano ruso
podría transformarse en harina en
Turquía para enviarlo posteriormente a
África y así aliviar la escasez de
productos en este continente